how are you good thank you for coming
and I thank you very much for this
opportunity mr. Dasher all right I'm
really honored to be here for the second
time actually so I'm going to talk about
Who I am and who we are I'm going to
talk about you know what DNA is business
looks like and how it has been pivoting
its business and then how it is trying
to expand its businesses in the US on
the in the West Western market so mr.
that's a kindly give you a little bit of
introduction of myself so i was born in
Kyoto and I was raised in island holy SH
cuckoo in Japan so I like mr. Daschle
mentioned I measuring archaeology
thinking that you know college life is
the only time that you can work hard on
something that don't make money actually
I was not smart enough to thinking that
way so I really wanted to be an
archaeologist I tried to be one but I
changed mind I changed my mind in my
senior year and I wanted to be in
business so you know I had no idea what
business was like I didn't see I didn't
know any difference between profit on
revenue so the choice I made was i
joined the bank because in japan some of
you might know these kind of large
companies tend to have really good
education system so my faster faster in
bank was when I got most of business
education being paid so does create
great time for me so after one and a
half years in bank you know the deep the
name of DNA the company of DNA pops up
in front he has a great opportunity i
met number song who is
the founder of the company and i joined
DNA in two thousand so DNA was founded
in nineteen ninety nine and i joined in
DNA in two thousand so it's been more
than TK it's being a great ride so i'm
going to talk about you know what it
looks like for me so i'm going to talk a
little bit about company overview so we
have now 15 offices worldwide and in
total we have around 20 100 full-time
employees globally and we make about two
billion US dollars about you and in last
year so last fiscal year enough
descending physically because it's a
quiet period so i'm not supposed to talk
about any financial for fiscal year 2013
but in 2013 last year we made around 800
million as operate operating profit last
fiscal year so this is the overview of
dnase brand portfolio and of course
business portfolio so i'm going to talk
about the history in later slide but you
can see how you know we have diverse a
business portfolio for the company with
twenty twenty hundred people so we
started as ecommerce company that's what
I thought I signed up for and you know
the e-commerce company on the you know
top left is still stable II growing
business with about 50 million revenue
parkour oh so we are public company so
you can find these details of numbers on
the website and then on the right this
service called mobile gay and social
games the main business we have so we
are currently making over eighty percent
of our revenue from this
gaming business and this is huge you
know it I think we're making 400 million
pakora from this business mainly still
in Japan so we make eighty percent to of
that you know eighty to ninety percent
still from Japanese market so we are
trying to make it more global and just
below that is the interest businesses we
have so we two years ago we acquire a
pro baseball team or Yokohama bestows it
is it is not you know uncommon in Japan
for the consumer product company to your
own pro baseball team actually most of a
baseball team was sponsored by these
companies so yeah so you know the big
nugget biggest team giants is owned by a
media company and we bought this
baseball team from TV network so why it
made sense for us it was because so for
this mobile gay business since it was a
really huge and we were spending around
200 million per year on advertisement so
that was at that time more than what
Toyota was spending and even coca-cola
was spending so when you are in japan
back in 2012 you were supposed to watch
our TV commercial 10 times of a few if
you live a normal life so we were
spending a little money on TV
advertisement and Yokohama Bay stars was
losing 20 million per year but owning a
baseball gives you a tremendous exposure
so you know the team is now called DNA
bases so that helped us a lot on
branding a brand brand recognition and
also brand image so and it costed large
around 1 million so we bought
sporting 4 1,000,000 and you know that
was I'm losing 20 million per year but
we could drastically cut the spending on
TV us so that it clinically makes sense
except that the team is not doing well
yet so it was cheap because that team
was doing a horrible at the bottom and
last season we are second from the
bottom so weird Emily better and you
know we hired a famous head coach and we
you know we structure the team so I'm
really expecting this team to be great
this year so far it's not I'm still
hopeful and we also own track and field
team that helps that helped us a
brand-new condition too so that sport
and we also have travel agencies through
an acquisition and I'm going to talk
about the other business later but we
have really you know fantastic culture
of entrepreneurship where a lot of
different employees with different
background encouraged to launch new
services so these other businesses like
entertainment and education you know
education these are coming from 3ds you
know new service approach that we
encourage you you know employees to
build new services so one thing on
related to this i want to add is that so
DNA actually now is recognizing japan as
the one of the companies that you would
go after graduating grade grade school
like talking versatile coaching hostage
is like you know Stanford or Harvard
because unfortunately the
Entrepreneurship shin you know start up
Shane is not as active as it is here in
Silicon Valley so it's really risky
choice for great studio
young young entrepreneurs to start up
business businesses by themselves but
DNA you know even though it is
recognized as game gaming company so a
lot of people who want to start
something new on something
entrepreneurial they come to join us so
that's how DNA is recognized and and you
know and and that's why you know we are
getting great people in these new you
know just new setup new new services
which I'll mention later so this is how
we have grown we launched we found it be
of I'm founded in nineteen ninety nine
and i joined right around here when we
had around 20 people and i actually left
toca headquarters around here when we
had about 150 people so you know if that
growth was really tremendous and fast
and that just kept me excited so I had
no kind of bored you know I didn't
experienced any time that was boring for
me and so this is how we you know I'm
going to oppose here a little bit and
talk about the history of dnase business
pivoting several times so when i joined
DNA it was number song and founder i was
trying to replicate the business of ebay
in japan in 1999 that was she that was
something she was really excited about
by the time I joined the competition was
really already tough so the first
presentation slide I looked at in the
first meeting after i joined the company
but saying yahoo auction which was by
the way the largest computer yahoo
auction was like an alpha
and we are like ant and you know I
didn't know about that and then so the
slide goes so what what what should we
do next so that was the first meeting I
joined so by the time I joined DNA was
really trying to transform itself into
something else to survive that time two
thousand it was right after what was
called internet bubble just got busted
so it was hard to you know raise
funds so we so we were seeing a lot of
other companies around us just going
bankrupt so so we were really sabha in a
survival mode so in two thousand we
shifted our business to more to online
shopping so from sea to sea auction
service to be to see online shopping it
was a close the Amazon I would say and
that was in charge of you know other
sales plus the these small store small
much you know margins want to sell stuff
on the internet so I was head of sales
department there and other pertinent so
we luckily we went profitable there but
there was a huge competitor is still
like Amazon like he's like like you know
and the rock can and we were just you
know very profitable but we didn't have
any service that was the largest in the
market so in 2004 we actually moved we
look at we started to look at mobile
internet that was way before smartphone
you know of course and that was even
before NTT DoCoMo that was the largest
carrier started flat rate plan for
internet mobile internet so buck buck in
that time you know the mobile mobile
phone was just for talking now for
internet but we started see a lot of
dating sites on some you know some fishy
websites starting to you know be
launching the the mobile internet no one
was really seriously looking at that but
we started we decided to make a bold
move to make a big investment in mobile
internet so we started mobile auction
from scratch we didn't use anything at
all from our old auction service and
that service went real well in like
three months we became the largest
mobile website in the world in Japan
alist so which means in the world at
that time so that made us go public in
2019 5 and then I we raised the extra
fund and we started mobile app business
that became largest tree so we were the
largest ad network on mobile it was just
like AdMob if you know that was acquired
by Google and then using that traffic in
2006 we started mobile social networking
side Paul mobile game mobile co XO is a
variation of mobile game in Japanese so
we started that you know we promoted
that website to the heaviest user of a
mobile auction so in the very first day
we are really confident that that
service went really successful so that
mobile social networking site was
virtual so we made money through the
selling avatars and we gave free free
casual games on top of it so people you
know didn't have options to find free
casual games at that time because you
know all the games on the mobile
internet was made by this traditional
gaming company who could never gave it
away so we started to provide these free
games and attracted traffic and you know
send them into social networking site
Facebook wasn't in Japan about me back
then and there was no big strong social
networking site in the mobile so that
business went really really well you
know everybody thought that it was a
really Korean business model because no
one was familiar with avatar business
but uh you know where I went really well
from the first day we weren't sure why
people would spend a lot of money on
buying these virtual close about so hot
we were making with 200 million per year
from that business so when that business
stopped growing we didn't know why
either that was that size of a business
so that business stopped growing so we
by that time you know we were to some
extent famous as an Internet company so
we freaked out we did a lot of things to
boost revenue for avatar we made it 3d
and we hire the role of silver it is to
sell these avatars but that business
didn't go you know go up even though we
were profitable so we had some we had
some peace of mind so we kept investing
in new things in 2009 at the end of two
thousand eight yeah soand of 2008 2009
we started to develop social games by
ourselves our first big kid our first
big hit game actually started to make 1
million dollars per day so that was made
by someone who joined DNA just I
explained in he graduated from Tokyo
University and he was not game at all he
was not even engineer but he come to he
came to DNA and he was asked to create
some great social game he actually
learned how to write code
in the company and then by hilton by
himself he made the fast social game
that started to make hundreds of
millions a year so from then so that you
know at that single game made more money
than the whole business we had you know
right before then so we started to shift
our resources into social social gaming
social mobile gaming in DNA so that was
when we had really rapid growth and then
we you know reached to the point where
we started to make billions of ready so
now we make two billion mainly like I
said out of social games mobile games I
actually in 2006 i started to be in
korea and then moved to china to
replicate whatever success we had in
japan in these Asian countries so I
didn't really experience all these the
last of the stretch of the growth but
you know I often went back to the office
and every time I went back to the office
you know the employees keep doubling you
know so that was amazing I expressed so
for those who curious about what this
the fast sucks the first big success of
a mobile social networking that we had
called mobile guess I'm well quickly
talk about this business because this
business is still very relevant to our
business and this is exactly what we're
trying to do here in the US to so
basically the mobile gay is the platform
on which we have all of freemium mobile
social games by freemium I mean you
don't have to pay to download the game
so you get to play the game for free and
you know as you proceed you can look
you can pay money to move faster or you
get stronger but you don't have to so
some users pay majority of our users
don't pay some users from order to play
fast and better pay for some virtual
currency or virtual weapon or buy time
and we are purely mobile so most of all
revenue a gaming revenue is coming from
mobile and this social so sushil when
when you say when we say social it is
about with about inviting your friend
makes difference in the game or you
compete with these friend or you know
you interact with your friend about your
squad maybe some of you might have
played some of these games like candy
crush so these premium mobile or social
about we are really good at and we have
launched 1000 plus freemium games on
mobile and we have 50 million users who
have who have paid for the game
cumulative and like I said we have three
billion annual revenue in virtual goods
so this is how the sad look looks like
in Japan so we have android app ios app
and smartphone browser and the future
from browser and we have you know here I
say it says pc browser so we have
partnership with Yahoo so if we will
Japan and sea games hitch on the vehicle
Japan it is run by us but its own
desktop and we have we create our games
in house and also we publish third party
you know fat bird game developers games
and we have unified virtual currency
with which you can buy these these goods
so we have we're running this ecosystem
tied up with this virtual currency and
ID so if you have ID and the past
passport and you have reason to play
another game in platform here in the
West on China and Korea we don't do
browser games so we just native up by
native app maybe that's what you're most
familiar with so these are you download
fastest browser games you open up safari
or chrome on phone and then play that
browser games is still big in Japan but
not here as you know so I'm going to
talk a bit about DNA expansion to the
west so I came here after spending two
years in China in 2008 so when I came
here its 2008 so the smartphone was not
big at all and you know the the mobile
gaming world mobile service mobile
internet market in Japan was called
color pebbles meaning that all these
specs or tech specs on mobile phones are
really unique so if you create a website
back in two thousand eight in Japan for
you know for Japanese mobile phone it
cannot be seen outside which path so
mobile phones are so different that we
couldn't just import ourselves into the
US and just run it so everything was
from scratch so we weren't even sure if
the same business model would work in
the Western or outside which pan so I
was just sent by myself so I was one
month department oversees Department it
had a name of department but it was just
me and I landed in SFO and I just rent
the office space in some material and I
hire 20 people in San Mateo and you know
we've been trying many
links to at least become familiar with
the market by the time that you know we
can we can be really confident of making
a big investment so from 2008 to 2010
and I was running a small team trying
many things you know like other many
startups most of the thing I've done
failed which was fine because you know I
kept planning and in 2002 by 2010 so by
to lose okay so this two years was in
really research is based on user huge
changes in mobile internet market right
up to not only launched iphone but also
open up in a platform for entrepreneurs
to create apps for everybody and Google
did the same thing so by 2010 we were
confident with the network you know
business network we had and the in
business environment he was seeing in
the u.s. so couple things smartphone
iphones and android phones were becoming
big in japan as well as well as well as
you know they were here so which means
you know we started to be hard to start
thinking competing with about competing
with Zynga and other guys in Silicon
Valley so the you know we need we
realized that we need to do we need to
make a big move and you know we feel
like we knew the market will enough to
make a big big investment so this is so
what you're seeing this slide is the
major acquisition that we've done in
each country is on area that we have
footprint here I was in charge of this
energy more coaccretion on alchemy lab
allocation so energy moco
was great a question because they were
one of the top iphone game developers
about them and they have great
management while we were still a lot in
feature from gaming market so we wanted
to learn the Noah of native smartphone
gaming in the development and also
Western market too so we see saturation
of managing moco we position the office
in San Francisco headquarters all the
business so the management of an energy
moco took responsibility of the whole
Western market and sees you know we felt
that it was challenging to hire you know
a little bit engine has in San Francisco
because of the composition so we
acquired the company whole utter
collapse it is a company in Santiago in
Chile so I didn't know until you know I
worked on this deal in some care but
there are great cake universities but
there were no great gaming game gaming
companies so a lot of engineers who want
to work on games didn't have any other
choice than joining gotta come along so
we had a really good position via we had
a really good position to hire a great
engineer so it is still the case so they
just keep I'm providing great engineers
for our gaming you know game development
so that's these San Francisco and
Santiago are really important offices
for us and we also have a studio in
Vancouver which we set up through
another different equation so we have
200 plus here 220 people here and 80
people in Vancouver and 80 people in
Santiago right yeah oh so here I am I
wanted to talk about talk a little bit
about how that acquisition and the
integration after that when because
that's the question I get
a lot you know it's a Japanese public
company buying us start up so you know
everybody was in hey so there should be
a lot of cultural difference how do i
how it went so that was 300 million
acquisition the steak was huge so we
couldn't fail the aquarium is no point
2010 at the end of 2010 we actually
ended up spending whole 2011 on
integration which we did not plan so it
did not go smooth of course so now you
know like I said imaging moco san fran
skull face is a head cold so now we have
really great team and we expanding but
the buckling 2011 you know I was
freaking out oh so I might have made a
huge mistake spending 300 million so
that came from some some several reasons
one thing is the you know it's not many
people who say this might be just west
vs japan thing but one surprising thing
I realized was the DNA the way the way
of doing business for DNA looked more
Western to me compared to energy McGraw
so any time ago when we acquire it it
was 100 plus people led by founder so
that was really optimized as a startup
company so everything was decided by
this fungus group of hunters and you
don't have to be you know too
transparent about how business was going
versus in we were massively profitable
and the reach we have strived to be
super entrepreneur we had really unique
company culture even in Japan so it was
really wrong to try to see Japanese
culture through DNA now about I realized
that most strongly when I walked
integration of the business example is
that we tend to disclose all failure
and you know the decision-making process
to employees to the really detailed
level and if asked questions you know I
will disclose anything worse as you know
the most of the startup company with 100
people can't afford doing that you know
they need to move really fast so you
know these people engineering engineers
and game producers were trained not to
step back and ask a lot of questions so
that was actually a big culture culture
gap we had to handle because in every
time something I have a lot of questions
I just kept asking around questions and
try to find data or report the reporting
was something you know this startup
company tend to skip you know they had
really well assigned responsibilities
among the team that was big thing and
you know we just try to honest and
transparent God didn't it'll feel well
with employees and founders but you know
gradually they realized how DNA had been
going through these people with this
unique company culture they released
they started to like it and they started
to adopt it and from us you know we
started to adopt this Western culture
another unique thing about DNA that
shocked people here was how we treat how
we handle people how we handle HL so in
DNA every time we see people start to
perform really well for example let's
say it's a sales department you know one
salesman start to make half of the
revenue every time we see it we put we
pull that possum out of the team and put
that person in this brand new assignment
we just keep doing that in that way team
started seeing the way to
you know create a structure to make
money instead of relying on one puzzle
so that's why I kept kind of you know
hoping around in different jobs but that
never happens in the US so you know we
started to you know say hey so this
marketing marketing has a bigger team
than we need why don't we just move that
person to game development and you know
people like no way no one would like to
do that because they have a carrier
passive marketing but gradually the
people here started to like that
approach I love this approach Pelosi no
I never get bored so those have culture
gap was you know big in the first year
so we spend holy a really integrating
culture and business procedure and as a
result we started to see we started to
launch profitable games in 2012 and then
now we are you know making next big move
and I want to quickly touch on DNA
culture so this is if you join DNA so
this is what you are told as really have
minimum requirement for the people this
is a big culture gap for the ng mukha so
the delight is kind of you know straight
forward on surface of sphere is a little
bit hard to understand this is as
opposed to pyramid shape of the
organization's we see the organization
as a surface and its sphere sorry and
you own the surface of the atmosphere
and if you're senior you know Europe
area get bigger and if you g near your
area is small but you own the surface so
you're facing outside the company and
representing the whole group whereas you
know pyramid-shaped organization you
deliver you walk to your boss who deal
but I'll walk to executives who
represent the whole company but here we
say that everybody represent the company
be the best I can be straight for
transparency honesty and speak up so
speak up as a little bit hard to
implement
so whenever you say you see something
wrong you have responsibility to speak
up whatever it is that seems to be fab
to me that I thought that this came from
a Western you know culture because
numbers on you know the founder
graduated from hover but that turned out
to be a bit hard difficult culture to
implement completely in the Western
startup organization so each you know
stage startup has optimized culture so
this is optimized for us as you know
culture that want to move really quickly
in entrepreneurial way in Japan sure how
are these five points use or carry them
around on cards are they in the office
or yes this is posted everywhere in the
office I you know globally and you have
to quit so the purpose is basically you
know these to be used in day-to-day
conversation in the work like we for
example so if you are kind of having
drink with somebody may be complaining
complaining about your boss you're
supposed to hey so you have to use
supposed to you're supposed to speak up
to your boss and the transparency early
industry you know if we have this you
know posted everywhere it's really hard
for managers to hide something you know
I wanted to all managers to be super
transparent so we didn't want to create
any politics and bureaucracy so this is
all about against bureaucracy and
politically traditional Japan India know
that you see some organizations that
have had this for a long time in Japan
and people take it seriously I think
that's the big difference is people
really look at it as a positive thing
here if a company tried to do that that
probably half the employees would laugh
at it well yeah so I mean everybody
comes to the office for interview
everybody likes this
but they get surprised when they really
see this is not just johns it's really
demonstrated in the office this is not
kind of you know the the goal got you
should grab a chip this is got a minimum
requirement so yeah if you miss one of
these he'll consider does you know
questionable and plea so so this culture
now i think is really well demonstrated
into it and the Western office I mean
actually every year in our global office
and so as a result you know we took some
detour in acquisition and integration of
energy moco now we are successfully
running you know these games so we had
multiple games in the top-grossing
ranking in in the US and now we are
known as one of the largest you know the
game developer in the West so actually
we have been so did all these successor
mainly from 2012 or are we 2013 but we
are being silent for a while because
starting 2013 we launched a huge
initiative where we develop fatty games
in parallel and all these 30 games are
coming out in next five next five months
so please look forward to it I'm really
excited so we be making these 30 games
and it's really a big deal for a game
one game company to make sorry games at
the same time so that's how the gaming
business plan so you know I wanted to
talk about kind of long-term strategy
but you know like I said these
fire-making 30 games a huge huge deal
for us and we are super heads down you
know
execution mode and we are trying to be
sustainably profitable in one quarter of
tea and so you know I'm happy to come
back here to share with you our success
I in six months yes and so I were to
touch quickly about other new services
so like i said no for the the whole past
14 years of DNA history we kept
investing in totally new businesses all
the time one of course to make money to
to really have for us to be super
flexible and entrepreneur so even though
ninety percent of oil revenue is coming
from games if asked by investor we don't
represent ourselves as game developer
it's not necessarily good thing for a
stock price you know that sometimes hard
us but we want to be always kind of
entrepreneurs so we want to kind of keep
something like Silicon Valley ecosystem
within the company that's how we keep
getting great people not only from Japan
ba from you know some places in Asia on
Europe and we launched last 12 months I
think we have relaunched about more than
10 new services and three of them have
been really successful we kill the
majority of them and I want to quickly
talk about these new services so one
this is called showroom this is a
real-time streaming live service for
artists for entertainment and you know
like you see you can see so in real time
you can show up as a cloud here and you
can say something too
single dancer and then they can respond
to it and you have to pay money to send
for us and this stuff it's going well so
far we just want it in november and the
other thing is manga box so as you may
as you might know some comic books a
huge in Japan if you go to Japan and get
on the subway everybody will be spending
time either on comic books or smart
phone num one was muffled and we are
trying to replay the place this comic
magazine but with smartphone so we work
with a lot of famous pose of famous
authors and really new authors so this
is exactly the business model that the
comic magazine I've been doing and
they're you know going down in terms of
revenue and number of copies that
they're selling and it's doing really
well and and it's actually translated
real time so you can check it out the
English version of it and we actually
also we have also entered the education
it market so most of school age students
in addition to school they either going
to add a private school to catch up with
the study for entrance exam or they
subscribe these educational malazan and
it's a huge market but it's dominated by
one big company and we are trying to do
that on smartphone with the better
content working with Tokyo University
with more reasonable price only just
moment in this symbol and it's getting
really great attraction and other than
that we also launched a chat service we
are working on some medical confidential
medical business I mean we all we have
we have some coupon service for grocery
stores we have many other you know III
can't even catch up with all these new
services and we want to do the same
thing here in the US as soon as we
become sustainable profitable so that's
how DNA has been you know growing but
yet you know keep I'm trying musing I
think that basically concludes my
presentation if DNA is only the interest
to you i'm not i'm not sure if I'm
allowed to you say this but we're hiring
so please go to DNA joke calm thank you
so let me come up and sit by you and so
I want to start off asking you a
question so when you in two thousand
decided we're gonna start that you know
go to work for a company that had 20
people in it and it's not your own
company you're not one of the first
entrepreneurs sounding right right how
did you explain it to your family ah so
you know actually my parents are a
little bit unique so they really worried
when I decided to walk for bank you know
about that he knew I got got I would get
bored so they were actually happy
hearing that I join a start-up come and
in looking at all of the things that our
DNA has been involved with I think one
of the most important parts of the story
is how you keep looking at new
businesses and new business models for
continuing the company's growth that's
something a lot of companies can't do
but i think you know to cut to the chase
japan's got a terrible reputation for
lack of entrepreneurship yeah how is DNA
so different how does this happen you
know how do you you know what why yeah
that's great question and so I mean
there i would say several different
answers to it one of them is you know
the management team a lot of them are
from either bang
for consulting firm they're really good
at looking at market and analyzing that
and analyzing it and making right move
but the first move we make well a scribe
out of necessity you know we didn't
really want to go bankrupt yeah and so
we had to make these pivots that were
not so entrepreneur you know we just
shifted from C to C to B to C dollars
car straight forward if you want to make
revenue more stable but you know I
started to feel good about these people
yeah especially when we moved to mobile
auction that went really well oh hey
this feels really good maybe we should
keep looking at new things always keep
looking thing so as you're looking at
new things now um company internal
development versus acquisition yeah how
does the company sort of look at both of
those as part of a general innovation
strategy right yeah so the still I think
have really we have a tendency of super
conservative in terms of these
investment so we been making these great
successful businesses from scratch but
when we started to make over 1 billion
in revenue you can't really keep doing
that it's just making one villain
business in the u.s. from scratch is
impossible so we knew that and we knew
that was something out invest our
investors looking you know at us so that
was also kind of album necessity we want
not necessarily confident at our
capability of looking at companies and
be confident with by you know making
this huge investment so he was really
scary haha if you had to go back to
Tokyo right now and kind of do the same
thing looking at possible partnerships
and so forth would it be very different
than what you're doing here um I don't
know so i mean if i were in tokyo yeah
how many so i was here in 2008 only
because uh only i am number son spoke
some English yeah so you know if I had
known the size when he missed maybe I
would have sent better bit up in a
businessman who knows how to buy a
company and you know they everything
about Silicon Valley ok let's open the
for the questions but I have a two-part
question some people say stop successful
startup companies in Japan have problems
globalizing because when they start a
company they only think about be being
successful in Japan and so they teta
towards the Japanese market and then one
successful then they try to goggle eyes
and it makes it difficult so the first
part of the question is the DNA
experience the same challenge in
globalization and the second part is now
that you have global company and you
continue to start new businesses are you
doing it the same way meaning that when
you start a new business are you still
only focusing on the Japanese market
first and then try to goggle eyes for
the position so we didn't we face a
challenge when we you know started to
make investment overseas and we the
biggest I think challenge we faced was
being seeing as Japanese domestic
company from investors and employees
here they have sort of pre assumption of
what kind of company Japanese many of
Japanese company would look like but
like I said you know most of the
challenge we faced was not really
because we were Japanese company we were
just new to the silicon valley so we had
to take our learning curve of adopting
you know the way to manage people and
way to work with other companies because
you know we're not really traditional
Japanese company in the way you know
that many people see us
but on mobile you know I really don't
see so accept these challenges or mobile
internet I don't see a huge difference
between Japanese market on the Western
market many game developers tend to say
hey this is to Japanese so you need to
change it but we often fail in that way
and we just launched our service in fact
in the u.s. top you know often goes well
cause better so that's a design issue
recognize game design does tend to not
be international you know different
markets tend to have our own different
preferences another thing is payment
systems hey it must have been really
hard to get used to different ways that
people have a paying yes I i I'm
guessing in behan still most payments
are going through the phone company uh
it used to be in that way but now that
most of these transaction are happening
on native app ok Google and Apple yeah
so that payment and headache is gone
except that you have to pay thirty
percent to google on the Apple that's
perfect for this game design yes so a
lot of game developers so we had a lot
of game designers from EA and Zynga they
tend to say hey this you I look to
Japanese so you want to change it and we
used to be with but when you do that the
a little failure that little mistake we
made was without understanding deeply on
how this compulsion loop and deep game
I've game bars walk you tend to make
mistakes to change these core game bars
so for us the experience has been that
it's better not to make these changes in
you know you I when launched won't again
okay yeah with your new businesses like
when you start a new business do you
look at the entire global market and say
how i optimize
business right on the global market or
still focusing on yeah so we are trying
to be global you know company obviously
from revenue standpoint to and a little
bit less than fifty percent of our
shareholders are already Western
investors so they see us you know they
are seeing how we do globally so we are
still making fun of money in Japan so we
need to be we need to keep you need to
stay good at that but at the same time
you know we want to be really aggressive
on Wes so we have no choice of really
just getting back into japanese market
and stay cozy in japan mug so everything
all this you're making we make basically
you know from global perspective why
don't you go to thank for home however a
new question first is what do you decide
to do a study Jeff Kellogg 0 plus us
bring them in stages and that variously
could you try again I couldn't find one
what did you decide to reduce 30 games
at one go and stay silent for two years
the 30 games I'm sorry oh so why did
wait wait why we decided to go with this
card games this already okay yeah second
what do you think TV are you guys
thinking about gaming on connected TVs
teeth okay great great question so if
we're going to ask fast mission so Doug
in 2012 we started to see profitable
games but that game we launched was
basically only around the game system
that we are super Gouda so we basically
in 2012 we made a lot of cod bottle
general the games which comes out the
current niche market so we knew these
games monetization mechanism works well
so we decided to expand our portfolio
and we wanted to play the game of big
company versus small setup because we
have a lot of cash so we decide instead
of just trying out slowly instead we
decided to make a big investment and
launch these 30 games in a really short
period of time we have five strategy
genres each channel we have several
games launching in one by one so that we
can just you know keep learning in our
game on adopt up to the later games so
that's kind of the strategy we had as
I'll answer your first question and the
second equation above are what we think
about TV yes so we keep looking at these
different devices so we don't treat TV
as something special so we also look at
these wearable devices we look at these
you know ipod and how you call it tablet
if you look at many different devices
but so far still smartphone and tablet
are growing really fast so we want to
prior prioritize these devices fast you
know maybe you don't know there are a
lot of Americans who don't know who
don't have smartphone yet and that are
still growing so we want to make sure
that we win that game and then it's not
too late once this you know great other
devices become big you know for us to
enter that market thank you have fun
yeah it seems you a really unique
employment structure and I'm wondering
whether or not your policy for taking
members out of a group and putting them
into groups applies between offices and
various countries around the globe or is
it within their own individual off yeah
we started to do that so we started to
move people from for example san fran
san francisco studio to santiago studio
we have a lot of experts from japan
that's obvious we have not sent anybody
from how we actually did so we
sent some people to Japan from San
Francisco but we started to see it but
the the magnitude of us kind of moving
people around in San Francisco is much
much less compared to Turing Tokyo I
mean we don't force posture of course if
you know when you if you're ng under
you're interested in visiting side we
always have open door and even
encouraged that people start with like
an internal job market and people apply
for jobs or does personnel sort of say
we think you should go here it happens
in both ways uh-huh but we do that only
for great performing certain business so
you know if people say well and I can't
do well in this department you know so I
want to move to define department we
don't basically do that I mean ed the
accepting department don't like to have
these people are so for the great
performer you know whenever somebody
start to stand up you just pull that
glass knob is that an indication that
DNA kind of has an expectation that
people will be in for a long time
lifetime employment kinds of
expectations ah that's actually great
question um maybe maybe that might be
the case but you know our business moves
really fast yeah so for last two years
is like four of a long time yeah so in
average tenure might be somewhere around
two years in Silicon Valley but that's
you know a little time for us done for
employees to express me many things okay
okay pores open again hi I'm Jimmy
recover from is identity I just like to
return briefly to the topic of
globalization you mentioned that the San
Francisco Opera is considered the world
headquarters I wanted to ask what is the
official language of the company because
i think really to be a global company at
some point you need to embrace english i
know some japanese companies you know
like
Bonnie and rocket Anna have tried to
make English the official language to
various reactions from the Japanese
business community but you know without
doing that I think it does you know
become a limiting factor trying to
expand overseas and just one anecdote
from my own personal experience I spent
some time at france telecom in their
orange R&D lab in tokyo and they act
even friends you know you think they're
very proud of their language but you
know they had selected english as the
official language of frantic on which
used to be a part of our moon but really
i think it's you know to ensure the
success their company that's to know the
best decision for them to make of course
it doesn't mean that every meeting is
didn't know in english but you know i
thought it was a you know a good
decision right yeah so we're not quite
there yet so DNA so san fran schools by
the the West Western headquarters so
still the global headquarters in Tokyo
we so like I said into banking two
thousand five or six I'm the only
employee who spoke ok English not
perfect but now most of people speak
some English many of them are really
good CEO you know he saw Maria's learn
English from zero to be really good
English speaker now so we are making it
for you know yeah we talked about
probably making kind of offshore
language in English but we know that you
know you wouldn't login day too so we
wanted to wait until our organization
get ready for it worldwide how many non
Japanese people are in the company um we
have said it non-japanese I I think it's
more than thirty percent or forty
percent Wow yeah because the the
headquarter day so 20 20 100 employees
or consolidated and I know that the hair
color has 1000 mm-hmm and we have a lot
of subsoil in Japan but here we have 33
8380 in look in America and we have 12
up 200 in China and we have
I think around that in Vietnam T so
maybe okay okay more than sorry but well
since um well what are people attrition
rate after a year the acquisition
because if you said yeah different
interesting cultures okay some people
adapt and some people don't so I'm just
curious yeah yeah so mom in energy who
called the attrition rate I the average
Kenya is little bit less than two years
which we thought was little bit longer
than average startup companies I had
that the google and amazon has much
shorter average tenure sultania the
average ten years a little bit less than
two years yeah and she surprised me I
mean show up for ja'von start out but
it's actually lower than medium stops go
ahead yeah what is your forward looking
for you on the social mobile gaming
landscape you talked about you know the
organic move you may have any food you
made how do you think that's going to
play out point forward great so the
mobile social gaming market Japan dot of
Japan is said to be around seven billion
Allah Garcia and here it's said to be
somewhere between like five to six
billion for the West some people say it
won't grow as much as it did in Japan
because in the USA especially people
have more than two TVs so you don't have
to worry about kind of occupying TV for
games but my view of this is this is
from kind of our experience in Japan so
these types of market basically should
be billed by the contents see if you'd
if you keep making crappy games maybe
the market will go down but if you make
great games that's how you make market
so you know we have accessed a lot of a
lot of another
Anna listen report about how investors
see market but we don't spend a lot of
time on it I mean some yes someone who
is facing it will grow a lot someone who
says they maybe it will stay around like
a 78 billion but we know that you know
us contents developer other one who lead
the market I yeah we don't make decision
based on you know these analysis so you
know you would not stop play games on
iPad because you feel like you know
doing so but you feel like you know
playing some specific great content
right so that's how we see ya so die I
gotta take the opportunity and ask from
the game industry perspective how has
DNA had to respond to all the questions
about data privacy and information and
this kind of thing yeah so actually
dollars a huge topic in 2012 so we da
topic actually hot you know we really
suffered from kind of background image
over hey you know these privacy issues a
plus you know the kids are paying a lot
of money on games addicted yeah but you
don't be we have been really doing her
best thing for these communities so we
invited a lot of high school students to
or you know even middle school students
to the company we try to communicate as
much as possible so we actually got hot
bye-bye them you know listening people
saying that the DNA is I've taken
advantage of this not doing good job in
the privacy and these things we have
been really sincere and we actually have
a committee headed by CEO just to take
care of these privacy issues and you
know its minority age pit wishes okay go
ahead conventions you're going to be
something's in six months but I don't
think I catch Brittany about these
development strategy here in US markets
what was your targeting customers what's
your yeah yeah yes we have I can't talk
too much and the details of this for
this reason strategic question but we
have like I said five different genres
what we think a really good opportunity
for us and we launched several games
parties different generals and each of
these general is on the game system was
tragically picked up and designed you
see I mean I can't say hey on the
academies in this way so I want to go
this you know path that's not something
I'm allowed to disclose at this point
but I can tell you that these you know
20 to 30 games coming up really soon in
a strategy jon is going to be a global
launch he will be our Western watch
these are games I talked about was for
West okay I'm Japan market has its own
different portfolio okay I want to get
back to the point about growth what was
the hardest part about sustaining growth
where you know everybody the number of
people in the office doubles every time
you come back in true so how this pot is
you know um when you become really
successful right so that by growing you
just keep adding a lot of restrictions
to your business yeah cuz you want to
prioritize you know the most lucrative
business is that makes it harder and
harder for us to stay entrepreneur and
so that's one thing another thing is you
know if you do something really
successful you don't react fast enough
to somebody else's success you know we
were looking at these korean companies
now there is a line and KakaoTalk
you are doing really well we didn't
react fast enough to these things
because we thought that we have really
great platform of a mobile and that was
kind of a huge regret regret for us and
if you didn't have mobile get songs
we've given we look deeper into why
these you know Korean companies made a
lot of money out of these instances but
when I look around you know DNA is like
one of the two or three companies in the
last 20 years in Japan that's really had
this kind of a growth right right right
and most startup companies in Japan kind
of don't what kind of advice would you
give to them why do you think they're
not growing more um you know we just
actually change the businesses right so
he know you were hungry for growth
that's one thing you're hungry for
growth and maybe the first time three or
four years when we were we have been
number two or number three I'm trying to
be trying to make the service that we
can call as number one service in the
market that speed I think still
continues so every time we make
something great you know we want to do
more and more and we tend to have like
long-term goal like three to five years
and set a really high goal you know of
achieving certain number of revenue
we've been achieving these goals
surprisingly so we just kept feeling
that you know we could do that since so
you joined in two thousand how do you
think Japan has changed do you think
that it's more entrepreneur is accepting
of entrepreneurs and I didn't we think
so I definitely think so um before DNA I
was working for a bank and you know my
job was part of my job was to make sure
that I get the passing guarantee on the
loan from these founders yes that was
part of her you know she there's a big
part of this the culture that is making
entrepreneurs to take risk but now I see
a lot of
people who I know you know starting
vinch of hand and you know start up some
some of them started to come here to
start up companies too so I'm glad to
see those changes ok I think that's good
go ahead Devon you first but you
describe your company to me like sounds
very unjust i specially imagine open
door type of the thing usually in the
japanese companies only the boss talking
to wrestle so many college graduates
always cause go to the pig industry now
are you are collecting all those and
exceptional weirdo graduates or is about
the young people would like to go to
your company instead of mitsubishi
actually DNA is one of the top
destination for these co-op students but
before we build that brand we used to
hire you know someone who cannot fit in
a normal organization so we have we do
have a lot of weird people we still did
but as we got famous we start see a lot
of abnormal you know book smart people
in a good way but less we are people
that i miss stops are the normal people
dangerous for this entrepreneurial yeah
it is smart you know it's not enough to
adopt adopt whatever culture we have but
we you know yeah we do we have a kind of
brandy high atop much people in Japan
that in some part might have changed the
DNA cuts a little bit but not in that
way but you know bulking the 2004-2005
we had a lot of people who I thought
would never be successful these big
companies they don't like to listen to
your boss and you know they say whatever
they want to say drinkman last question
I know greenie is also a very famous
Japanese mobile and social gaming
company so what's the biggest difference
between D and a and agree and what's the
strong point audience Ian strong point
compared to green a DNA strands strong
point some very big regret yeah so I did
great people they have collection of
smart people too there are more full
custom games so they represent
themselves of of mobile social gaming
company that's how they you know hire
people we do lot more things other than
games which is generally not necessarily
good thing but we have our business port
for you as much wider than three we on
the social gaming I can say we can we
head to head concussion in Japan and
here in West but maybe you know we might
be hiring a little bit different clever
people who want to do not just games but
many other things which I could say is a
strong point it could be having a weak
point to for investors you know we are a
little bit hard to evaluate from one
kind of metric as a game company because
we do a lot of things differently so
that I would say both of kind of
good-paying on we are we go eat point
but the interesting thing about
innovation is that often you see things
coming up between two different areas
and so I think the diverse approach is
very interesting well it's colin into
the formal session we've got some
refreshments outside we hope you'll stay
around and meet dai and talk with each
other for a while thanks for coming by
thanks very much
you